the key thing you did right talking
about boom and bus Cycles you raised
that secondary for double click you also
were able to to sell some shares
yourself and lock down a win so explain
how Founders should ride the cycle I'm
in agreement with you the valuations I'm
seeing on startups because we do do
preed with our accelerator and we do
seed right around the the the point uh
in time you're talking about typically
500k uh but you know 500 to a million is
pretty close uh and the same kind of
thesis right you figured something out
you got some traction you can't fake it
uh generally speaking
so this moment in time is the time to
build and there are some advantages to
building in a down Market what are the
advantages to building in a down market
and then hey you know in another 5 10 15
years if it's a crazy up Market what's
the proper thing rational thing for
Founders to do in both markets compound
question there I mean always like I tell
CEOs the number one number your number
one job is not run out of money so the
three main reasons companies go to
business the first one is they solve no
known problem uh which I think gets back
to to the the the do as well as today
where people are investing in cool
technology uh let's say crypto or nfts
exhibit you know our current examples
they solve no known problem blockchain
okay great another another leder been
around nothing new uh so a lot of money
goes towards that so yeah I think people
are focused more on you solve a problem
the next reason they run they they go
out to business is they don't raise
enough money and then the third reason
is they raised much money look at all
the uh we're calling death of corns I
don't know if that's a word we made up
or that's a give me that one up yeah
death accor Sal okay death accor so all
these these companies that raised
hundred million doll last year they're
going out of business it's like yeah
what the hell kind of governance is that
I I don't I don't understand yeah that's
just not responsible so that's just
those are just bad you know again
business doesn't change e economics
doesn't change and and we really pushed
that on our on the founders you've got
to build business is really simple you
solve you find a big problem you solve
it better than anyone else and good
things happen you know people give you
money um and if you do a really good job
they give you a lot of money and then
you got this thing called profit and
then once you get profitable then you
then you don't have to depend on anyone
but on the flip side if you do get into
a as we tell Founders you get into the
growth phase where you have a Playbook
it's replicatable and you have a high
degree of conviction then you got to you
got to use capital A lot of people are
like well I can borrow money that's a
lot harder these days but yeah you know
the whole debt financing like debt
financing of a tech company is just I'm
sorry it's absurd get some debt get some
debt as a sort of a insurance policy but
if you got to use debt to grow an
unprofitable business you're screwed
everyone's screwed it was incredible I
guess in the Zer environment I had
series a companies that didn't really
have product Market fit they were truly
seed companies fig figuring out product
Market fit but they were getting serious
evaluations and then yeah different
banks were like well we have this money
sitting here so we'll give you you raise
20 we'll give you 5 million you raise 30
we'll give you 10 million and then the
founders just tack that on to their
Runway okay I have 18 months of Runway
I'll just you know I'm spending a
million a month so I rais this 10 I
raised 20 so I got 20 months and then I
got 10 million in Venture debt or seven
that's seven more months and I like no
you're not supposed to use it for that
rainy day fund but don't use it as way
because then a VC has to look at your
deal and say okay I'm paying down 7
million in debt I'm putting another 20
million in and 7 million goes out the
door to pay a bank that doesn't make any
sense um and in a down Market with this
globalization happening how do you think
about work moving around the planet
because there's something unique that
happened with remote work you and I were
in the in office culture for two-thirds
of our career and here we are you know a
lot of people want to work from home so
do you believe in work from from home or
do you think people should be in offices
we'll start there yeah I mean I was
talking to the uh uh I'm going to forget
his name now he's at the Hoover
institution but he's he's like the
expert in in sort of this whole work
from from home and I was like what
what's the answer we just ended a binary
answer there is no answer I'm really
torn you know I I think for certain jobs
and for certain types of people working
at home's great I think that it's really
bad socially and I think you get more
done when you're in the office yeah for
our work I do board meetings now you
know with a you know five minute notice
you know I'm in a board call as opposed
to traveling for three days and wasting
time that's great but most people aren't
that discip you know a lot of people are
disciplined you know they they need
mentorship they need they need help they
need socialization yeah there's a
socialization part where people get
weird working from home staying at home
all the time they need mentorship that's
a lost part of this and I'd say the top
20% of performers are more uh effective
at home it's probably about another 30%
that are equally effective in the the
bottom half are not nearly as effective
as if they were in an office being
mentored and part of the yeah I I'm
trying to reverse this at my companies
and it's just incredibly hard because
you have such a great talent pool of
people at my Venture firm with 22 people
and then we can hire people faster than
in Silicon Valley and people don't want
to be here anymore and it's too
expensive to be here so I would get a
lower quality person who wanted to be
here versus this incredibly High per
quality person at a lower price will
stay longer it's it's incredibly
frustrating in some ways but it does
seem to be reversing I'm curious I'm
curious for you I mean you're you're a
uh uh you're opposite side of the
spectrum as I am you're extroverted very
extroverted yeah it's got to drive you
crazy not to be
socializing it's maddening and um I am
now reversing it so I'm going to get
like a space just so I could have like a
co-working type space for my Founders in
my portfolio because I do need to be out
and about I host events I do Jam
sessions one of the things that um I
learn from from Travis from Uber he'd
have these like jam sessions chisako
would do them too we just five or six
Founders we get around just hang out
have dinner or just hang out at
somebody's house and talk about their
businesses for a couple of hours and try
to help each other think through
problems and strategies and blind spots
and so I'm sort of codifying that where
I do these jam sessions every couple
weeks bring together 20 Founders you
know go to uh our Law Firm Wilson cini
or F Wick's office get a big conference
room and just talk for 4 hours and it's
really really energizing for me and then
doing the Pod you know I get to talk to
you and other you know investors
Founders from around the world and that
does fill my bucket and give me that
energy but I I I think this has been
great for introverts who you know they
they get to focus more and getting rid
of communes if we didn't have the
community issue I think this would be
like people would be much more open to
coming back to work here in the valley
Apple I think is four days a week now or
four days a week in the year there might
be three or four right now Zuckerberg's
kind of forcing people back and then
roadblock said either come back to the
office office or res you know
resignation accepted um so I think they
did it like a gentleman's riff basically
you know we're going to reduce the force
by the number of people who don't want
to come back to the office so I think
it'll start changing I also notice that
um people looking for work from home
jobs are saying that they're having a
hard time finding them you know as you
get a thousand you get a thousand
applications because anyone can be ex
can do that job right so now and then if
you're a Silicon Valley person who wants
to work from home you've got the expense
of Silicon Valley but you want to work
from home you don't want to get on the
bus I understand it but now you're
competing against somebody in
Portugal Argentina
Manila Canada whatever it is and those
folks are going to have a cost of living
that's 1/5 oneth of the cost of living
you have so they can accept a salary
that's much lower and all the management
Kevin have learned how to manage remote
workers and that's actually the thing
that is really mind-blowing to me once
you learn how to manage a remote worker
in South America Canada port Portugal
Manila whatever it's no different it's
all the same you're in a slack room
you're on Zoom you're doing huddles
you're using notion or Koda all it's all
the same so I think it also increases
efficiency are you looking to build a
SAS product you need help on the
technical side listen developers
expensive we all know this and they're
hard to find but if you use Dev Squad
they're going to help you validate your
idea and bring that concept to Market in
3 to six months how do they do this Dev
squat is a fully managed agency that can
handle product development end to end
this means you're not going to just get
developers you're going to get technical
product managers designers and more all
for the price of just one US developer
this means you can focus on what you're
good at product strategy sales marketing
and they will do all the idea validation
the real user testing and they are able
to do this because there is amazing top
talent in Latin America an entire
product team for the price of just one
US developer think about how much you're
going to get done by leveraging De
squad's amazing talent in Latin America
a technical product manager that's your
main point of contact right and then
you're going to have product strategist
ux designers devops and quality
assurance alongside that product manager
making sure that your product and your
project is a success so you pay
month-to-month no long-term contracts no
lockin starts at just 40 bucks an hour
and then they can scale depending on
your needs so I want you to visit Dev
squad.com twist that's
dsq ad.com twist to get more details and
to get 10% off your first month
oh